(audience cheering)
- Welcome back, everybody.
Our next guest is a
five-time Grammy nominee
with more than 25 number one hits
as an artist and songwriter.
Not too shabby.
He has a new double album
dropping February 17th
called "My Story, Your Glory",
but he's got a special
holiday song for us today.
Now performing "Come Home for Christmas",
give it up for Matthew West.
(audience cheering)
♪ How long has it been ♪
♪ Since you felt that feeling of wonder ♪
♪ Like a child wide awake ♪
♪ Countin' down on Christmas Eve ♪
♪ We're in such a hurry
for life to begin ♪
♪ Do you ever just wish
you could go back again ♪
♪ What if I told you the
young and the old you ♪
♪ Are not quite as far
apart as you might think ♪
♪ Come home, come home, come home ♪
♪ Come home for Christmas ♪
♪ Let your heart return once again ♪
♪ To the joy and the peace ♪
♪ The love and the hope ♪
♪ It's all right here waiting ♪
♪ For you to come home for Christmas ♪
♪ And come home for good ♪
♪ Come home to a manger ♪
♪ Come home to a story that's still true ♪
♪ Come home to a Savior ♪
♪ Who came down from heaven just for you ♪
♪ How long has it been ♪
♪ Since you and your
heart talked to Jesus ♪
♪ Come home, come home, come home ♪
♪ Come home for Christmas ♪
♪ Let your heart return once again ♪
♪ To the joy and the peace ♪
♪ The love and the hope ♪
♪ It's all right here waiting ♪
♪ For you to come home for Christmas ♪
♪ And come home for good ♪
♪ Come home for Christmas ♪
(light music)
(audience cheering)
One more time for Matthew West, everybody.
His new album, "My Story, Your
Glory" drops February 17th,
so be on the lookout.